كشفت وزاره صناعه السعوديه عن ارتفاع
اعداد مصانع الادويه والاجهزه والمستلزمات
الطبيه الى مئه وتس 139 مصنعا بواقع 56
مصنعا في قطاع الاجهزه والمستلزمات الطبيه
وثلاثه و80 مصنعا في قطاع الادويه خلال او
حتى نهايه اكتوبر الماضي وتسعه وزاره
الصناعه الى العمل على جعل السعوديه مركزا
لصناعات الادويه المهمه عبر زياده انتاج
الادويه والمساهمه في رفع الانتاج المحلي
وتحقيق الامن الدوائي كهدف استراتيجي ضمن
رؤيه 2030
الجدل حول اسعار الادويه في السعوديه لا
يتوقف فمصانع الادويه المحليه التي ازدادت
مؤخرا وتغطي نسبه كبيره من احتياجات
الادويه في السوق السعوديه
يقولوا معظم مسؤوليها انه ليس بمقدوره من
مساهمه كثيرا في تخفيض اسعار الدواء كون
معظم المواد الاساسيه المستخدمه في تصنيع
الادويه تستوردها المصانع من الخارج
الحقيقه في مبادرات مختلفه قامت فيها ااا
يعني هيئه الغذاء والدواء وجهت الحقيقه
المستثمرين الوكاله الموزعين شركات
الادويه لانه في حال وجود مشكله او كون
السعر عائق بالنسبه لتوفر الدواء لا توفر
الدواء يكون رقم 1 وبالتالي ينظر في موضوع
السعر معالجه ارتفاع خففه على حسب
الاحتياج ان شاء الله
الاسعار في الصيدلياتي ومواقعها
الالكترونيه مرتفعه فمثلا متوسطه اسعار
ادويه اضطرابات النوم يصير هنا الى اكثر
من 100 و50 ريالا بينما لا تتجاوز قيمتها
70 ريالا عند الطلب من المواقع العالميه
وعند المقارنه باسعار الادويه في بعض
الدول العربيه فان دواء حساسيه الانف
بالمملكه يقترب سعره من الخمسين ريالا اما
في مصر لا يزيد على في 10 ريالا لذات
المنتج تسيطر المشتريات الحكوميه على اكثر
من نصف حجم سوق الادويه في السعوديه
فهل تشهد سوق قرارات تلزم المنتجين
العالميين ووكلائهم بمراجعه تسعيرات
منتجات الدواء الوارده للمملكه البالغ حجم
سوق الدواء فيها 30 مليار ريال سنويا وفقا
لاخر التقديرات
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
من جده ينضم الينا الدكتور حبيب الله محمد
التركستاني استاذ اداره الاعمال والتسويق
الدولي دكتور حبيب مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه يعني مساله ارتفاع اسعار الادويه
وصحيح اللي هي مساله اعتقد عالميه الان
لكن الى اي مد هذا الارتفاع الموجود في
السعوديه هو يعني يتوازا او يتماها مع هذه
الحاله العالميه الموجوده
الاسعار
لابد ان يكون السعر المناسب ل همم
لجميع المواطنين هو وجميع المحتاجين اللي
همم الدواء هو الحقيقه وسيله للعيش همم
همم في حياه امنه ومستقره ويستطيع منها
الفقير ويستطيع منها غير الفقير الحصول
على الادويه اما بالنسبه لارتفاع اسعاف
الادويه نعم هنالك في مبالغه في اسعار
الادويه في كثير من الاحيان ونحن لنا نتهم
جميع الشركات بان هي العامل الرئيسي في
زياده اسعار
الادويه ولكن احنا قلنا ان هناك نعم يوجد
مبالغه في تسعير بعض انواع الادويه التي
لا يتمكن المريض من الحصول عليها في الوقت
الذي انت تقول انه لا احنا اسعار الادويه
الموجوده عندنا وارتفاع امر غير مبرر لا
يتوازي ابدا حتى ما حاله ارتفاع اسعارها
عالميا فبالتالي المبالغه ما هي اسبابه
اذا كان الامر بهذا الشكل
طبعا اول شيء اول حاجه في المبالغه هو
يعني لا مؤاخذه يعني عدم الشعور بعض
الشركات المسؤوليه الى مجتمعيه تجاه
المجتمع وما يسمى بالجيش على التجاري يعني
هذا طبعا الامر طبيعي ان الانسان يحبه
يعني ينجح ولكن في قطاع الادويه يجب ان
تكون السلعه ليست سلعه الراسماليه كما
هي السيره
الصناعات او في
الانشطه
التجاريه
الادويه لها خصوصيه فالداخل في هذا القطاع
لابد ان يتوخها كثير من الامور التي تعني
بشؤون المجتمع فلذلك انا ارى انه يعني لا
يمكن للشركات يعني تكون 100% هي خاصه
ومملوكه لافراد او لشركات خاصه ان يعني ان
تصل الى هذا المستوى ان المسؤوليه
في يعني منظمات غير ربحيه تكون شريكه مع
هذه حتى يمكن ضبط الاسعار وتكون الاسعار
يعني في مستوى بحيث انك تحقق الحياه
للشركه ولكن بهاء الشرق ليس معادل لهام
شريحه الذي يتوقعها التاجر او المستثمر في
قطاعه اخرى غير القطاع شكرا جزيلا لك من
جد الدكتور حبيب الله الثاني استاذ اداره
الاعمال والتسويق الدولي